the thieves reportedly used a tricycle
to transport the boxes to their padlock
Cutters guys you should never have to
compromise on Comfort Helix has
mattresses with cooling technology that
helps regulate your body temperature
whatever the season by supporting Helix
you're allowing them to support us in
our show go purchase your Helix and
thank us later for your best night sleep
Jay Helix is offering 20% off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners go to helixsleep.com
DPT use the code Helix partner 20 this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep starts
now huge thank you to our sponsor prize
Pi prize pick is the most fun that we've
had winning up to 25 times our money
this football season and now you can
play during basketball too you just need
to select two or more players pick more
or less their projected stat STS and
place your entry go to prize.com DPT and
use the code DPT for a first deposit
match up to $1 that's prize.com DPT use
the code DPT for a first deposit match
up to $100 prize Pi daily fantasy sports
Made Easy hey Townes welcome to another
episode of Dum people Town population
population zooker Z zooker the Jack
tuck pleasure to be here Jack Tucker
zooker Tucker the Jack Tucker of Zack
zooker the Zack zooker of Jack Tucker
how are you stamp town I'm doing great
I'm very happy to be here it's been my
dream so dumb dude I love your I'm just
going to start by saying this you are
probably to many of our listeners
whatnot this will be an introduction of
you say absolutely an unknown but you
are you are for our fans and listening
we have great comedy fans so we have
great comedy fans who may know but for
fans who don't know this is a dude who
we were lucky enough to meet several
times through
the festival and heard about before we
heard about your show stamp town and it
is insane in the best ways that insane
is can be hilarious and funny we're such
fans of yours and I'm so happy we made
this happen and that you're here oh man
yeah we've been trying to get this in
for about a year now cuz we we were
having we basically only saw each other
once a year in Austin no and then we
text each other throughout the year
being like can we make it work loud
talking over music and after party no
we'll knew it I promise man we'll make
it I'll get there it's in my calendar
right now two days later I can't do that
I'm not turns out I'm actually going to
be in uh Saudi Arabia and then I'm in
New York but then I'll be there for that
window closed that window closed we'll
find another window we'll find another
window do you know I think I told you
guys this uh the first time when I met
you guys but do you know that I used to
intern at the UCB theater and when you
guys on Saturday nights and and 2012 and
2013 and I used to work when you guys
did the scar Brothers shows and I so
Saturday night I was a Tuesday night
really is that like a was that like
before Bangarang was Tuesdays it was it
was it was uh 201 11 2012 I was I did it
for 14 months cuz remember back then
they just didn't keep track no you just
let you go I feel like we definitely
cross path for sure that's when we met D
I love it yeah I was that was Tuesday
nights that's we met then met because it
was comedy death rate Comedy Bang Bang
and then Douglas movies was before and
then Diamond lion was afterward look at
you guys now I love you both two Titans
of the industry and here's here's the
deal the world is getting Dumber I don't
know if you've experienced this in your
you you play some of the dumbest
characters ever what do you mean and
what you saying but like Jack Tucker is
the dumbest but smartest but dumbest
person ever and I feel like you might
you the quickest dumb person I've ever
se you m a lot of Comedy from his
stupidity and so you and the fact that
audiences love it and laugh understand
that the world's getting Dumber this is
what happens our fans sent us stories we
still are on you can send them on X or
Twitter whatever the hell you call it
it's I think I might try and find
something new okay cuz we'll have
everything up to where it goes and maybe
some will trickle in but maybe we'll
we'll start trying a new platform I
thought you were going to start calling
X something new and I was like oh what
are you going to call it call it truth
social I'll play around I'll play around
with the threads feature SE bombed
really quickly right like no I think for
a day nobody's been there in a month
I've not I never even I I after the day
I was like get this [__] off my profile
get it out of here threads is like after
your parents go in the home where you're
like we'll see them all the time no then
you're like I think it's been about
eight weeks checked in on threads I hope
they're doing well should we call I
think it's dreads is happy there it's
fine see someone else with a number
another number of it I'm sure they're
having I just found out I had two
followers over the last few days it's
fine we see really quick this is dumb
and then we'll jump straight into your
story this is dumb did you guys notice
Instagram did a thing where it showed
you what number person you were that had
signed up for threats and then I go get
rid of this and it goes if you get rid
of this you'll never be able to bring it
back and I was like yeah we're on the
same page delete it and then it would
show up and I'm like yo get out of here
man I don't need to be I don't need to
know that I'm 7 million I already kicked
you out of this party you're not allowed
to come back through the window and it's
just a guy with a number I got a
notification of the day from Instagram
it's like you have 148 new threads
followers and I was like they were not
we're not going anywhere
no following happening well Dan they
want to follow you thank you maybe we'll
try it send the stories on fun if we
just populate like threads was on the
ropes until News St brothers and Daniel
vankirk brought it back so here's a
story sent in from by Derek Shipley at
Derk Shipley thank you
buddy uh I'll go with the headline first
uh as we customarily do um and yes there
is an animal let me this is a pre
headline thing preer we don't like to
talk about animal getting hurt but this
is a deer which is kind of like we are
back to where I I used to do all three
you know and now we each B one so an
animal went down label them Story 1 2
and three like when we put them in the
dock so I I don't even know all I know
is story do it let me do it all right
York dear shoot if it better be like
dear shoots Hunter York County police
arrest nude man might be probably me uh
after school bus stolen with dead deer
inside so I don't know if he killed the
deer no I yeah this is my I'm going to
predict okay Dan I can't wait to hear he
picked it up on the side of the road the
deer and sex with it in the bus why
would you make it on
me if you went to that far he
said in the not in the bus on the bus in
the bus youo where's the weirdest place
you've made Whoopi in the bus in the bus
was like the probably either show on
he's like you good it's dead on the side
of a three-day dead deer and he's like
you good come on buddy like he's in his
own n I'm not leaving you over the
shoulder carries come on come on we got
this also naked yeah he's naked and he
stole a bus this is Adams County
Pennsylvania I'm sure okay I thought
when York I thought it was new man oh
not in
England I like that they blamed somebody
for this County this is Adams County
could be Amish it's Pennsylvania a man
was arrested in York County after two
chases with law enforcement in York
one of which police said involved a
stolen school bus with a dead deer
inside Pennsylvania State Police in
Adams County said early Tuesday morning
Trooper stopped a vehicle with the
Florida plate FL I mean this is Florida
disseminating their stupid in other
states they're like Florida plate if
they touch that yellow line light let's
get them let's search them just in case
just just why why cuz I I swear to God
this happened to me I just on tour I
don't know where this is dropped there's
more rose gold dates we'll do that [__]
later but I was on tour and I saw two
Florida plates in a row and I was on the
phone with a family member of mine and I
go I saw two goddamn Florida plates in a
row I'm in Ohio what are they doing up
here and they did not seem to be
together yes and I'm like what are two
Florida plates doing up here 8:00 in the
morning I it's not good I think they're
going to one's going to see the other
play and they're together and he's going
to try and drive up next to that person
and that person's going to think that
they're racing and immediately they're
now going to continue to r two Florida
plates if two Florida plates interact
outside of that state it becomes a
Highlander situation there can only be
one of us hear me out classic Zach
Zucker pun mode what is a Florida plate
like a plate what type what would you
imagine a Florida plate to be okay a
Florida plate is definitely like a mound
of
Meth hot dogs uncooked hot dogs I was
going to say Chinese food with hot dogs
in
it some like Disneyland food as well $40
water bottles it's a decorative plate
they saw Florida plate uh decorative
plate on Lincoln Way East as part of a
burglary investigation from the day
before State Police say Troopers
interviewed the driver Tony Saunders
during the stop and say that he claimed
he was coming home from work oh yeah he
was you know coming from work I'm just
coming home from work I'm aamp yeah
driving home better be a semi kind of
got off of the wrong exit deer and kind
of kep
going where are you coming
from whever wherever let me yeah the old
ball and
CH a dead deer in the back of this all
right during the stop State Police said
the Troopers learned of a theft at
rudder's convenience store in York
County according to least Saunders said
items from Rudders in the vehicle and
say he claimed to have gotten them them
at a junkyard and the vehicle is a bus
or this is the first chase this is the
first Chase vehicle so those those giant
bags of Fritos in the back of the car
junkard that's from a junkyard junk
those junkard junk food junkyard that's
where they come from the three of you
any of you ever done a junkyard no where
you go to the junkyard I I had to and
you get to work the I had to get a new
hood for my Pontiac Grand Am way yes and
I didn't have the money to do this so
and I needed a new hood was damaged and
so I went and found one I mean you the
Heyday of grand amps they're just all
they were like Legos they were just all
the same right you take one from the
junkyard and put it on and what was the
conversation with the guy who worked at
the junkard got a haggle what what will
you do on the hood on that grand cuz it
you know there was like four colors and
I just found one that mat how out of
breath was he when he stood up oh my God
it was a lot and oh pants never fit he's
overweight way overweight no no
suspenders down suspenders lot of
pulling and a collar that's too loose I
love a guy who pulls his pants up that's
one my favorite yeah just always just
they say I'm going to get my sun back oh
okay not this time not this time new I I
was when I was just in Tucson this this
last week I was driving from Phoenix to
Tucson two of my favorite cities there's
a do you know that there's like an
airplane junkyard in in the middle of it
and they just have all these old planes
and they used to do like art exhibitions
there and I would love to go and hang
out there and I don't know if buy them
but so there's one in the desert right
near here called the Boneyard we've been
in it we stood on the wings of the plane
when we shot stuff for the United stats
of America TV show we were out standing
in these planes and that was really cool
that was really awesome that's a
junkyard so he says I got this stuff at
the junkyard Troopers also saw a dog in
the back of the vehicle and a dead deer
in the trunk got him in the junkyard
dead deer in the trunk and a dog in the
back of the car the dog here's a great
dog this is the great thing the dog is
just going for a ride having fun dog is
having the faster you go the more wind
do the dog's like this is [__] great
dude deer in the trunk bro there's a
dead deer you will go for R and the more
that guy's running from Rudders to the
carb when he steals [__] the more the
dog is excited like this is a game yeah
he's running getting fast this is fun so
he said as the Troopers tried to open
the car door stay police say Saunders
drove off yeah always a great move
classic cops are like we need to get in
there they're not going to get if I know
my buddy that's what he does that's
right he's consistent Troopers follow
the car to hover Street and they say it
drove through a chain link fence okay
always wanted to do that that's 8 that's
80s action movie right right but it
won't explode the way you want it to
it'll just kind of like wrap around your
car your tires fck your your hood up
yeah Trooper said the car then continued
through tree lines and got stuck on
train tracks They saw Sanders run into a
heavily wooded area behind a vacant
Cross Keys Motel where's the dog where
is the dog dog's back back at the car
being like what do you guys I know but
sitting on train tracks come on you got
to get that dog out that dog's out I'm a
good
boy we did it that's just a dog
mentality so later Tuesday morning
around what time what time do you think
10:30 in the morning what time wait
sorry this was this is later on Tuesday
morning when they were notified that a
school bus was I feel like it's midm
morning 10 saying after the kids were
dropped off at school well that's what
he said I'll say uh I'll say
9:15 I'm going to say 3 a.m. 8:45 and I
think on some level I would love it if
he had to make all the stops so he's
running from the police he's like get in
open the door get let's go he got stuck
in a drop off line and and the cops are
stuck in the drop off line too there's
no way to get well if the stop sign
comes off the bus then they have to wait
but they they cannot cut they cannot cut
every day I drop my daughter off at
school every single day I there is no
day that goes by that don't utter what
are you doing move
Do not drop them off right here I can
ask you a really dumb question high
schools don't have parking lots for
students no they do mine some do yeah
but in La yes but if they don't and
you're 16 and you drive yourself to
school you just have to find parking
like any other no way there's a parking
lot there's a parking lot at their
you're wrong I'm you many cars that
would be for students uh there's like a
multi-level thing at my son's high
school well that's I mean his school
high school is dope
but that's also you get in the valley
yeah you're the the other side where'd
you go to High did you grew up in New
York or uh I grew up in I was I'm from
New York but I grew up in suburb Chicago
so I went to Highland Park High School
to park I'm hphs baby I'm from Rell
Illinois out past to K South of Rockford
had a lot of friends from Highland Park
a lot I was Buffalo Grove into Highland
Park nice off Arlington dude yeah going
to Highwood and see what was going on in
I played Highwood I played basketball
and baseball in Highwood like Wan you
know everywhere welcome back welcome
back to the Chicago suburbs talking
about the Chicago land area and all let
talk about more suburbs there now the
355 extension has come in what about the
Dan Ryan Dan Ry don't get on that4 all
the way to I9 the guys going down to
WKA down Toka yeah if I start in
kosha what happens now oh my
God in the corner come on you got to so
you ready for the time not to not time
is it I don't want to you said 10:15 you
said I said 8:45 9 9 at 710 a.m. so
probably the the the the bus needed to
do a job and guy and the kids yeah
weren't getting to school that day we've
been saying this since we started doing
this show together that is not in the
morning this is an all night the night
this is this EXT time it is for him this
is the end of the night not the
beginning no no yeah he's not slept he's
not had breakfast let your kids out at
the bus stop and you're like well he's
coming he's coming he's just been
hurling through the woods until he finds
a bus that really was a junkyard that
better be Chopper in the in the uh in
the car with the dog from stamp oh my
God all right so Carol Township police
were notified the school bus reported
stolen so it probably was stolen even
the whole thing's a whole time there has
been a bus no no he was in a car theun
dead deer in the
thing left on the train tracks ran
through the woods stole a thing so so no
kids this is preschool hours maybe
Elementary School we don't know we don't
know all right so School reported from
from Abbottstown has been spotted in the
Dillsburg area I just love all the names
of these D I want to move to Dillsburg
yeah deals with it yeah deals with it
wasn't Dillsburg canceled yeah Dillsburg
was got really right wing right wing
Dillsburg we're sweet
too I love it uh Dillsburg we relish our
you son of a [__] that's so bad uh High
School's got to be the spears right
dillberg if you hit a Dillsburg you're
in quite a pickle thank
you Dillsburg we're right on you'll love
us on the side all right um officers say
they found the bus in a shopping Center
parking lot and tried to stop it they
say the bus left the lot this guy will
not be stopped he cannot be stopped
might not be a school bus could be a
charter bus could be onto Route 15 North
winding in and out speed this is now
you're this he's like I can't I don't
stop if I stop we all go and he might be
sort of Dennis Hopper depending on the
era you never know police say the bus
left the highway and drove over a burm
do we know what that is oh hold on this
is a this is a land uh thing like a I
want to say like an elevated area of
land to allow irrigation to go on both
sides whatever you told me I would
believe that yes bur yeah dude of course
so you're confirming it yeah
unequivocally you're telling us that
he's right run on this platform confing
we're just going to hold you to this
forever he's confirming the BM I confirm
the BM that have been Bernie's uh
campaign feel the BM the burm confirm
the I'm asking you again what is a BM uh
I mean
10% Carol Township Police said the
driver ran into a wooded area again
another wooded area his move he's
trading for a triathlon that's his move
it's like I drive for 20 miles I run for
miles into the woods then I has a hook
shot he runs into the woods right up
Peter style he was later found running
through local parking lots he is
training for something by the way
multiple parking lots lots so not just
one he's running through he there maybe
it's like a multi-layer like the high
school you
knowk it didn't say a parking stru
multiple going through tra Joe's there
he is over there in whole fots he's in
Zs oh he's in zils what l
all of
them the police say the man stripped his
clothing as he fled oh cool he was
closed up until this point yeah so the
closer off they won't recognize him if
what was Dave ael's great old joke if
you see a man running naked down the
street run with him you run with that
man cuz whatever he's running from is
just penis flapping in the breeze that's
awesome no reason run with him whatever
running from is some scary [__] all
right uh police say Sanders admitted to
taking the bus early in the day after
crashing the BMW it was a
BMW claim the dead this is what he
claimed this is where it goes to D
people Town claimed the dead deer was
for garden fertilizer what is that true
can we get confirmation on that Dan I
mean you I mean all those organs and all
that
stuff I mean look kind ofm depends on
what kind of BM you're trying to make
yeah yeah you said the organs EX exactly
can we all pitch a show called BM notice
BM notice BM we just go around the
country asking people if they know what
a b burm is do you know what this is BM
notice you're on notice notice uh police
uh here we go say uh Sanders he admitted
taking thing they say Sanders faces
charges in Adams County of fleeing and
attempting to elude officers evading
arrest or detention on foot recklessly
endangering another person trespass my
motor vehle vehicle and other traffic
events so why so it goes back to why
would you drive off when the cops are
there something is clearly like the dead
deer in the trunk that he's claiming is
for but it's just a deer like well it's
a fertilizer I gu it's fertilizer for
the garden all right according to court
records Saunders also is facing charges
in York County for fleeing receiving
stolen property resisting arrest and
reckless driving oh no he's mad about
the the rudder the rudder stuff in the
he's kind of trying to prot from
meanwhile some guy at a junkyard is like
I gave him that [__] I gave it to him
that's the only part that's the only
part that's true so many bags of Fritos
I don't know what to
do racks too I gave him the racks I
didn't need those I had this deer he
said he was trying to make a
garden Grandam Hood he was looking for
court records have listed Saunders will
get out as living in both Steelton and
I'm going to ask you you may not know
but these guys may know a town in
Florida that we have a huge affiliation
with Port St Lucy you got it oh wow got
it I was say St Lucy in is I'm going to
say it [__] up yes Port St Lucy have
you been Dan did you go no but I have to
at this point St Lucy has come up so
many times on the show I'm not talking
seven I'm talking about over the span of
you love years like 40 times 100 at
least 100 times at least so the
connection is not that you guys have
been there it's that it's always always
[__] we get so many stories from Port S
A lot of them green
always [__] ry's got the next one we
don't know how old that dude is we don't
know how old I what happened to him we
don't know what don't know how old we
don't got to do it every time wild and
dumb as hell it's a wild and dumb Story
I mean if you're naked and running and
you had a deer in your car meanwhile
meanwhile I hope that dog found a
forever home yeah that dog I hope that
dog's running through the woods of its
own heart
you he is either living with one of
those cops or a train conduct who needed
a friend or you know so yeah or and the
de yeah yeah him and the deer went to
heaven and went to summer camp that dog
is froling 12 years from now the cop is
tucking in his kid to sleep and the
kid's like tell us how we got Rusty
again said there was a naked man with a
dead deer and then you go into the
living room and there's just a dead deer
in the thing and it's like that's Rusty
also I feel like maybe maybe like you
know people wouldn't run from the cops
if we could Rebrand them so like maybe
instead of like alluding cops what if
there was like elude cop like a cop in
some like dumpy underwear shoulder maybe
a little bit of ankle that Reno 911
scene where they teach like they teach
him how to dance yeah is it the man or
woman who's like proving he's sober it's
my favorite my favorite thing it's the
great kickball
chainet it's like she's like man did you
take dance he's like no I'm just
drunk got let's do that's the best all
right we're going to take a break we
come back we'll find out I guess what
we'll find out what Dan's doing no you
guys oh us we find what we're doing and
where you can see Zack zooker it's the
scar Brothers in Danny vankirk it's dumb
people town we'll be right back
Bo hey guys welcome back to the show I
don't know where you went in the
meantime but we're happy that you're
back we should let people know what's
going on with us I think this is going
to drop relatively soon and in doing so
um we can tell you
we're going to be in Springfield
Missouri at the Blue Room uh doing I've
never done that room before very excited
but the thing we really want you guys to
come to is we're doing our Twan show in
New York at RS NOA theater 511 uh very
excited and I was probably a little
under half sold right now and we just
want to sell it out let's what on it
it's November 12th it's Sunday night
it's part of the New York Comedy
Festival Sunday November 12th 7:00 p.m.
two man show called identical dads it's
our it's stories it's the one main story
week yeah I think so great that'll help
my plugs later on there you go so one
it's one story and and about our lives
about how we were potentially mixed up
when we were 6 weeks old and it follows
that throughout and then how we tried to
figure out our own identities through
our own experience as kids and then
parents and what it means to be I love
this show we've been rehearsing it a ton
we did it over the summer here at
Dynasty typewriter we basically
unintentionally make the case for why
you should have kids by telling you for
an hour and 20 minutes how shitty it is
to have kids yeah it's good time would
you guys be um how would you feel if you
found out you were is it that you were
maybe mixed up yeah so we go into that
whole thing I don't want to tell you but
we actually find out spoiler it turns
out they're two hot
twins become the turns out we're the
Lucas
brother you guys have fully
switched brothers so that's on November
12th it's a Sunday night 7:00 p.m.
arsova at theater 511 we'll post all
that stuff up we would love to see you
guys out that and then go to sup.com cuz
we're December we're first and second
we're in Cleveland at hilarities which
we all love then we're going to be in
Portland at Helium for a night beginning
of January and then Seattle back at the
end of January beginning of February in
Denver we're just got a bunch tons of
dates coming up super.com check that out
uh Zach I know you've got a stamp town
on November 13th here in LA in La yeah
we've got some stuff that I think will
probably be missed in New York in the uh
first two weeks or the first weekend of
November I've got a stamp out on the 5th
Jack Tucker my solo show I'm doing my
Off Broadway du so you can come watch me
jack off Broadway jack off Broadway jack
off Broadway jack off Broadway and then
I'm going I'm going back to Australia
I'm going I'm doing a a show on November
17th in Sydney a show November 30th in
Melbourne and then I kind of take the
rest of the year off until next year
where we do some runs in LA and London
and then I do this longer uh five to
eight week run of Jack Tucker in New
York at the Soho Playhouse and I'm show
ho happy to do it I love it showy I
start on it's going to be a great time
I'm very exited so fun sound effects
everything like unbelievable for people
who don't know I mean this is like a
ridiculous kind of hilarious stand
forche belty standup comedian super
physical crazy fun amazing sound effects
worked into the show it's almost like a
Duo act with the sound effect which is
so the time from a Duo act from a du a
double act that IES on timing the timing
you have with the sound cues in the show
is just go see it I highly recommend
that you guys check this out when it
comes your where can people follow you
and know when all this stuff is coming
up um I'm usually posting it always on
on my Instagram or on the website
website sttc comedy.com Instagram is
just zachor Zucker um and you know and
then you know if you ever want to just
come find me in real life I've been
taking a lot of dance classes all over
Los Angeles dude I love the dance videos
follow him to see the dance videos look
I'll I'll shake I'll do whatever it
takes kick ball chain dude yeah look I'm
going to kick ball chain Beret
Beret uh no he is he's an amazing dancer
and again just as far as physical comedy
goes just some of the best I mean like I
would argue it it's so interesting
because we're sitting here in like three
kind of very different but connected
types of Comedy this is why we all get
along very physical very I mean you're
so in your body all the time you do the
stuff you do Dan is such a good
character person and a phenomenal
Storyteller and this is a Twan comedy
thing it's like three very different
types it's playful we all just play the
same way I yeah we there's a joy to it
all a joy to it all we go for the the
big laugh and the four big bit hounds
right
here I love a I love a life bit I don't
give a [__] if no one ever sees it life
bits like I'm the funniest when no one
sees it you come on man that's that's
what I'll tell people I'll tell my
family too I'm like that one was just
for you this is just for us sometimes
you're just Z at the Ellen
[Laughter]
show
is know helped set that it's the before
you jump in ran a burm any last oh um
that's when you do that cool thing to
your hair yeah that's that's C it Cur it
you it up it sounds good and then you're
going to be like oh you just fancy named
something we all know a flat strip of
land raised bank or Terrace bordering a
river river Canal so my raise thing was
right or the second thing a path of
grass a path of grass strip beside a
road oh so just the grassy median yeah
great so that's where he bur in context
again call it the median yeah God damn
you don't make us look [__] up all right
shut up you guys ready for this one this
one is sent in by Jo G this may be a new
person
sending Joey G you got a problem with
said this stuff F you I had a chicken
parmesan let me tell you something about
the chicken parmesan
do you know there's an old video of
Randy and I from where Dan you've seen
it from our bar we were at someone's bar
mitah and we and 13 years old were you
guys of bar mitz age we were 13 like
from 84 it's onag you should post it
once a year we should post it every
during bar during bar
season I'm cra we're in three-piece
suits and it's like we're little Mafia
dudes I'm like it's a wonderful fa you
look good over here I said I'm like yeah
I'm the the better half the better half
of that I'm like you'll get it some D
they look like they're in the St Louis M
you'll get it some a nice facility it'd
be a shame if something happened to this
facility faity incredible did you guys
always were you guys always bitten
around we were doing bits and we were
like fuing for the camera in a way that
toally ate that almost choked a kid that
was funny too there was some weird
aggression but you tell you were friends
get Danny winterr away from that get out
I got to talk about the facility before
we hop in I ask a question that I feel I
get asked a lot and I'm always curious
cuz I've never asked other people did
you they always say did you always know
you were going to be a performer or like
or did you kind of fall into it so from
personal experience I played sports but
then when I look back I'm like oh I was
like doing my eye black and always
wearing my wristbands and I had all this
stuff and I was like oh I'm like clearly
like early seeds of being bisexual was
like oh yeah I'm like literally doing
makeup and doing full drag to go play
baseball right now you
know predisposed and then you just get
funneled into how that what what you're
supposed to do we didn't know what was
possible and I guess coming from the
Midwest and coming from St Louis we're
like we didn't understand what could be
but we just understood this is our
superpower amongst people is being able
to gather a group of people and make
them laugh whatever that meant that had
there was no like oh then we're going to
go into standup comedy or we have an
Uncle Jeff who did this I think we also
were very cognizant of like even at a
young age like we don't want to be known
as just the twins we were like we want
to be so silly and funny and like that's
awesome have a running gag with so many
people so that was like how we met our
best friends we were like if if you can
hang in this bit then you're in you're
in if you can hang with this then you
are in what we're doing also just
remembering that you guys are from St
Louis my buddy uh who's an amazing
musician this guy Lucas Tamron uh he's
the lead singer in the front man of this
band called thumpasaurus he's from St
Louis oh no and we were chatting and
maybe you guys are the people to do this
with we've been wanting to write a movie
for years about a guy who um his dream
is to fly a plane through the arch and
his grandfather died doing it his father
died doing it so he has to avenge them
and his like wife's like begging him not
to do it but he's like I have to do this
so I think it should be two brothers who
and they should be called the wrong
Brothers not the right brothers that's
so funny I mean and they're called RG
we're writing this we're ring this movie
I'm the wrong Brothers nobody's ever
pranked the arch people have pranked the
Hollywood sign I told this story about
how we PR so we're up in the top of the
arch and we're looking down must do
say Dan came with us we tried to get him
up into the arch and he got into
elevator which is a tiny little going up
there and he's like I know my
limitations and limits he said my limits
an elevator I would do it I just I don't
like I get is there no stairs in the you
wouldn't want to walk up the stairs just
fall all the way down so we're up high
and I'm looking down there's snow on the
ground cuz it's the winter and someone
had walked out the message Jesus is
number one oh and and queen isn't that
the truth right go girl we're not going
to argue with that as Jews were like we
got to do something here and as
comedians were like let's do something
funny so I walked out in the snow yvan
day is number 11 Ivan De Jesus who was a
utility played on the Cubs also played
on the ph and he was number 11 so then
for the rest of the day people went up
at the arch and looked out and were like
is number 11 and your commitment to to
stamping that out this is what we did
when we young I mean
about okay Jo G at Jo
g128 it's amazing all right you ready
for this birthday happy birthday happy
birthday Joey happy birthday you son of
a [__] son of a [__] come smack your
face give a little me joy 1028 cuz he
always cared about his birthday you dum
you stupid meatball as the pant hey it's
almost my birthday time it's my birthday
that's what he says as is the two weeks
two weeks and so what about you yeah 6
months from now it's going to be that
day why does your pocket smell like
prute I got three weeks till my half
Joey
1028 my long two days before two weeks
after my quarter birthday I remember
like it was just yesterday it was about
5 days before 5 weeks before my 30th
40th fth birthday we will start this
story no maybe we won't I know so guys
do you guys like comedy What's your deal
I love it what's your inspiration talk
about life bits sneaker thieves o
sneaker theves one of my favorite bands
the sneaker thieves sneaker thieves
steal and we're going to get into how
much a large amount of money worth of
only right-footed sneakers because
they're idiots so this is the thing that
you know like sneaker head stores will
do the only one that's out there is the
right one is the right or we don't know
if it's right or wrong we don't know
this could be wrong could be right so
they just stole all of this a two-part
two-part gig they got just dummies a
group of Thieves rep sto they're going
to have to put the lefts back out to
sell the shoes so then you so we got get
we'll come back and hit them again okay
all right a group of Thieves reportedly
stole more than how many sneakers from a
shoe store in central Peru you're like
hey where are you going for those
sneakers down at aife down in the Lowry
C cool kicks cool kicks overose yeah
yeah oh I love cool kicks kick is great
you know cool kicks K from fresh kicks
acoss the street really what Fairfax is
like it is now I go with my son cuz he
loves fresh kicks and it's like hot
shoes epic Town cool kicks is amazing
look I go there nobody likes me right
next to leave me alone I've seen you
guys I saw youall with all the shoes Co
but you got to cool kak now we're going
down to Machu Pichu where's that on
Fairfax it's in Peru Peru really let's
think about this what would be the
benefit to stealing All rights it's the
most then you get to find out what's
left thank
you jack off Broadway over here if
they're big enough it doesn't matter if
you have that Eugene lovey condition
from best where both with literally or
do you think they're stealing them and
then telling them if you want them backs
you can sell the
things I mean I guess you how do you
value the value zero on shoes that are
all right feet he's all right imagine if
they split them it's like well if the
the shoes you know 250 bucks and you
split it down the middle it's like well
one
shoe's 125 yeah I was like I almost went
175 and I was like would make this okay
is if for some reason it was like you
know it's a in this area of the world
like people don't have shoes so you're
like hey this is better than but then
it's then it's like did they steal or
did they unknowingly made off with only
right foot sinkers the theft apparently
took apparently took place on Sunday
April 3 according to the Diario Coro a
national newspaper that covers Peruvian
and world events security cameras portly
show three people breaking into the shoe
store which is located on juano the
capital city of junin region at around
what time what time did the security cam
they break in on a Sunday oh the
security Camas are showing it what do
you think it's on the day of day of our
lord it's got to be late at night okay
what do you think 11:30 p.m. Dan I
disagree with you they're all at elcia
they're all at church and I'm going to
say it's taking place at 9:00 a.m. I'm
going to go uh also same deal I think
I'm going to say 7: a.m. get your
answers in townies because this thing
took place at 3:30 a.m. he's the dude
you're in the ballpark that's
smart and the trio carried out uh three
large boxes that were filled with about
how many shoes how many right
shoes box so they don't even know but I
mean I'm assuming these are big boxes
not just boxes 189 189 very good I was
right off the bat what do you
think I'll
go 300 300 what do you 78 get your
anwers in Towes because they came out
with three large boxes that were filled
with about 220 this right here wellknown
name brand sneakers so lots of
Zips and
one tons of AAS the [__] sportif there
go the thieves reportedly used this is
where I was like this okay this is where
I'm like now we're in Dum people town
the thieves reportedly used a tricycle
to transport the boxes to their padlock
Cutters according to di a tricycle yeah
I mean it's 3:30 in the morning it's
sort of a dolly I guess oh so did they
ride it or IM riding it like clowns with
these big box on oh they were doing that
shitty thing sometimes people to like
they stacked it and then they did did
were trying to keep pressure on the top
and the back so you can push it without
it falling over you're like the Grinch
with all the presence oh yeah Dan great
reference Dio reports that it took the
small crew an hour and multiple attempts
to break into the store let's not call a
crew that's you ham line you know Ham's
line from the town this is the not
[__] around crew this is the [__]
around crew they're barely a CRI hey we
had to transport these things what did
you bring to transport them a tricycle
and what did they say an hour of
attempting to get into the store so this
so now I'm going to get into what you
this is all a question about what you
guys think this store in central Peru
has cuz that's really what it is this
your car wash in Silver Lake yeah yeah
no it's like what you think I maybe I
should say this for the end how much in
dollar amount we know that it's
220 right Fox Business reached out to
the National Police approved for comment
like the National Police approved they
were probably like who who they're like
Fox Business we we're on this story why
why and who because we're looking for
the police are reportedly investigating
the crime and trying to find both the
thieves and the missing sneakers so
that's usually how it goes the cops are
like well what we're supposed to do
basically is uphold the law and then
give consequences for people who break
that law so we're trying to find the
sneakers and catch the guys who do it I
mean the most [__] response ever
we've gathered evidence at the scene
great local Chief
Ed
right and a broken
window provided the pro with the footage
and the fingerprints we are able to
locate these individuals this you are
describing the most boring episode of
CSI it looks like there's a break in and
we will look at the
crime so here's the bummer the shoe
store said the Juan Kyo CSI Juan Kaio
CSI ju King Joe 1028 you know what I'm
saying police in the area believe the
stolen sneakers are being hidden because
the products can't be sold do the like
CSI Miami like puny line that comes
right before the looks like the shoes on
the other foot now oh that's that is
already perfect yeah thank you uh social
media users appear to be entertained by
the sneaker gone wrong ha this can only
happen in my country when Twitter uh
Twitter user wrote in Spanish surely
they wanted to sell it at Half
Price let's do like all of these as the
final
whoever stole these shoes probably leans
left so s so sorry I laughed because the
owner is still losing but one user wrote
by a long laugh Anam mopia all right The
Botch sneaker I won't even give it that
I don't even get that you know what I do
say this I pray for their souls that's
that's good that's
good this thing's uh we're about to
we're about to lace this thing up yeah
all right sorry bot sneaker Heist isn't
the first thing to happen in Peru in mid
April a similar sneaker theft was
attempted at a shoe store in eeka a city
in southern Peru but the National Police
approved stopped the theft and seized
the sacks of sneakers that were valued
up to we'll do this value of the other
one in EA and then we'll do the value in
ours how much in our in US Dollars yeah
Us in EA the one that was EA that they
stopped how much were they attempting to
steal in terms of merchandise uh I'll go
$500 what do you think like
$5,000 yeah I was going to maybe say
like 4600 okay get your answers in
because they were valued up to
9,447 lot I knew it was a lot according
to a separate report published by De
Coro on April 16th so we will get out of
here on I mean just so dumb are these L
bees dude are they stealing some BH I
don't know maybe some Lou bees a little
glaga
there we go a little Jordan fors all
black they're all Jordan fors all black
God damn it I love those I would go I
look I would Rob for that I would Rob
for some Jordan fors are you kidding me
my son got some with his own money with
his own money damn wow my daughter wants
some and I was like son is he what size
shoe is he he's now like almost where I
am he's like 10 and a half 11 why I got
some great 13s I'm looking to get I'm
going to just unload I don't want to
they're so there're some Jordans oh [__]
no there's some they're they're really
nice just all right speaking of really
nice how much and they said they or no
this is the
one the left all the left handed left
footed shoes how I'm not this isn't a
joke they don't value this literally
half of what so I think this is the
value of the sets but you obviously
can't sell I know sto damages it's
almost damages I know who stole the
shoes sto Sho here we go Jeremy Irons
there you go my left foot that's right
folks
yes all right um how much it's
approximation yeah but if we hit 9g on
the last one did they note that to build
it up because this one's lower something
sh0 220 220 shoes I I'll go $6,000
$6,000 very good what do you think Jay
I'm going to say 11,000 all right yeah I
want to go higher two I'm going to go 13
13,000 one of you is exactly right now
we play now we get to play the game who
do you think is exactly right do you
want to stay where you're at or jump to
another wait what are the three numbers
again 6
1113 [__] do you want to we'll let you
st hold on 6 11 13 move around the
numbers it becomes
1028 my birthday it's Joey Joey G what
do you think I'm going to stay with 11
I'm staying with mine 11 you going to
stay on 13 yeah I mean like 11's my
favorite that's my lucky number but I
feel like I should just stick to un you
can move if you want oh God stand on 13
stand on 11 stand on six okay he I want
to just say in our hearts we want to be
right but it's more of a thrill for our
guests to be right am I right Dan no
okay yeah as as a first timer here I
don't give we get out it get it we'll
get out on this story on this and then
we'll let you know what Dan's got going
on and he's going to take us home all
right stolen merchandise is uh value to
be
13,000 he's won all
in I just wanted someone to if I moved
and God forbid that wasn't it you know
then you were right to ride with the
youu that brought you wow I got to ride
with the me that brought me here and the
me that brought me Dan with the you that
you br to the dance all right Dan can
you give us just a little tease of what
we're going to see in segment three um
sometimes uh you can love all dogs but
wish it lived somewhere else there you
go all right it's a dog story on the
other side of the break it's dumb people
Town Zach Zucker the three of us will be
right back with more dumb people town
around sound there's more
people guys I want to talk about our
sponsor Helix I love them the lineup man
they offer unbelievable 20 20 unique
mattresses including the awardwinning
Lux collection which you have you love
the newly released Helix the elite
collection a mattress designed for Big
and Tall sleepers and even a mattress
made just for kids AB I love these guys
you take sleep quiz which so I sat down
with my daughter who needed a new
mattress she was like redoing her
bedroom and I was like okay this is the
opportunity we're going to get a helix
mattress we took the Sleep quiz for her
and it was fascinating because I'm like
oh you sleep this it's interesting to do
I said you sleep this way cuz I sleep
this way and she needed it cuz sometimes
she gets hot the night and she wants
this type of a thing takes two minutes
to take the quiz so easy we ordered the
Helix It came it came in not like an
enormous box and it comes in this very
manageable box and we got it up on her
new bed and I'm tell telling you like I
will go in there when she's not there
and I'll just lay down and sleep on this
thing it is such a wonderful mattress
and she has gotten the best night sleep
of her life which for her as an athlete
as a student as someone who's like
staying up late that sleep is so
important I'm so happy she has that
healing they're American may they come
with 10 to 15E warranties depending on
the model uh if you don't want to take
our word for it he likes the number one
mattress picked by G take our word I can
tell you from personal experience it's
amazing so here's the deal uh Helix is
offering 20% off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com
DPT use the code Helix partner2 this is
their best offer yet and it won't last
long with Helix better sleep starts now
guys I want to talk about prize picks
Jay it is Fant I've had so much fun
playing with well now okay with
basketball season totally and pick combo
projections across football and
basketball from the specials League I
love this a league created specifically
for combo projections that include two
or more players from different sports or
leagues for examp LeBron James and
Travis Kelce for a 10.5 combo of three
pointers made and reception that's
insane It's So Dope because combine I've
never seen that before I love it and you
if you want to play alongside some of
prize picks favorite players rapper Meek
Mill buddy Andrew Schulz great comedian
you can now find Community plays under
the promos tab of the app very easy to
ous app and a fun app by the way to to
you ENT some of the biggest names
Curry's been lighting it up in this
first week I'm going to pick him for
more than 29 points how about yic for
more than 10 rebounds that dude lives
and feasts around the basket i d Lillard
you think he's lighting it up as we
talked about in our in our Sports
podcast how about more than four
three-pointers made I'll say more than
two past the logo first of all the as we
said the site is really easy to use the
app is really easy to use it's very very
fun it makes games that like and and
players that you may not care about or
watch now you're in the next step of
fantasy football so Joe burrow more than
two passing touchdowns Travis Kelce more
than 75 receiving yards these all feel
very doable and it's very exciting to
watch and then Ro I love it so go to
prize.com DBT use the code DPT for a
first deposit match up to $100 that's
prize picks.com DPT use the code DPT for
a first deposit match up to $100 we're
having so much fun playing prize picks
you guys will too prize picks daily
Fantasy
sportsy around sound
there's hey guys welcome back to the
show before we jump into number three
Daniel tell people where they can see
you and all this stuff gosh so this is
it this is the a big week the rose gold
tours going to going to continue for a
few more months but this week if this is
a
Tuesday uh tonight I am in St Louis I'm
at the Old Rock House and I if you're
listening to this you know I I always
love that when you do a show and you're
doing a meet and greet afterwards and
somebody's like we heard about it today
I had people who they found a babysitter
for the three kids drove an hour and a
half to come see a show they're huge
dump people Town fans I love that too
I've had dump I've been starting out
shows sometimes depending on the show
maybe I'll do it uh when I'm up later
but if I open up the show I've asked
people for dumb Stories We I've had some
great RI off those so bring those bring
a dumb people T story uh I might get to
uh talk to you but that'll be St Louis
and then tomorrow night I am in
Louisville at Planet of the tapes and
then the 9th I'm in Indianapolis White
Rabbit 10 Rell Illinois tickets might be
all sold out I don't know and then I'm
sure tickets are all sold out for
Saturday shooting my special in Chicago
on 1111 L and then I'm in Austin on uh
December 14th everything's at Daniel Van
Kirk go see everyone we've spoken to
who's come see you is like so happy that
they it's a fun hour it's a really
really fun
love congrats on shooting the special
that's so cool on 1111 as well perfect
time to make a wish to wish that it's
going to be I hope it's going to be a
good time it's going to be great ready
yes yes Salem couple's dog chew up their
winning lottery ticket God damn it
godamn it every time that's on you it's
hard to be mad at the dog because the
dog doesn't know so chewed any that was
just the thing they chewed that so
remember the dog chewed my homework I
mean there's all that stuff that's like
a thing take now you can take a picture
of your homework and put it on Schoo G
and send it in whatever but people are
like dogs don't chew up paper and do
that that's wrong my dogs if there's a
package in the front of our like
they eat it up they chew up the package
like it's [__] out the dirt the this
makes sense you left your lotto ticket
where it shouldn't have been why aren't
you like in a dog bowl yeah so dumb
covered in dog food you left it in the
BM and it was the dog that was rescued
from the bus the dog BM yeah Salem
Oregan where uh I'll probably coming
back to next year Salem organ a Salem
couple sent Lottery officials a torn up
ticket after their dogs multiple so
another let me get it yeah yeah oh you
got that winning lottery ticket food
they want hands away from its face if it
was a winner just for fun so they just
had like a scratcher or a ticket they
don't maybe Auto picked their numbers
they don't know what their numbers are
or it's I think this is a scratcher
right and they're like well what if it
was a winner we don't even know they
send it in to somebody who gets it on
their desk like what am I supposed to do
with this right now turned out it was a
winner oh my God Nathan and Rachel
lament uhhuh lament lament they lamented
the back in how do we this is Salem
Oregan how do we know she's not a witch
guys I'm a trial the other Salem other
Salem either way still she's not a thing
though I didn't know there was another
one uh they sent the damaged lottery
ticket in with a picture of their two
dogs apple and Jack aged 11 and two
years old he said they left the ticket
out and the dogs decided it was
delicious according to the organ Lottery
anything no they saw paper and like mean
that my husband thought it was hilarious
and someone might get a good laugh at
the very least he said for sure it's a
winner so this is a deal where he's like
the fact that they chewed it up and we
scratch it I the dogs know when you're
asleep they talk to me what but because
the couple couldn't check the $3
Pharaoh's gold crossword Pro tip
crosswords suck I hate the crossword
scratchers it takes way too long to find
out you L don't give me something to
just give me my numbers and then give me
winning numbers that's what I like thank
you Dan thank you for having the guts to
say that you know what thank you for
thanking me you're welcome the guts that
you had thank you for having the guts to
say thank you and thank you for thanking
him in front of me to be able to witness
this the you had to witness it thank you
for being here and being willing to step
into gratitude Circle great episode let
me I'm going to get out of here they
mailed it into Lottery officials who put
the ticket back together code for
lottery officials have the easiest jobs
in the world what's what am I doing
today I'm putting a ticket that check wi
five pieces turns out they had one the L
couldn't believe they'd actually be
getting money back despite their dog's
Antics that's too funny Rachel said we
are definitely it's not that funny we
are definitely getting more chew toys
they go through a lot we love them but
they are crazy sometimes Lottery
officials now recommend keeping the
tickets out of pets reach oh we will
close out this episode with this how
much money did they win how much money
did they win on the $3 Pharaoh's gold
crossword
ticket I'm trying to tell from her
reactions cuz it's like she's not like
oh my God she's like it's funny yeah so
what do you think it's like 40 to 400
bucks lock like lock it in lock it
in $40 40 bucks I think they won $3,000
3,000 cuz they could be rich and be like
3,000 won 3K I think they won $5
$5 I'm changing to 800 I say so low I
don't they went through all that to put
very very short quick fun little three
sentence story friend of mine recently
told me that their parents won
$25,000 on a scratcher no what when she
was in high school uhhuh told her like
two years ago this was like 20 years ago
this the first time your friend yeah the
parents just sat on that's not money for
her and they said we we we uh bought it
at the gas station did it in the car
took ourselves out to breakfast and then
paid off the rest of the mortgage God
and just didn't tell anybody for
years but you imagine that energy with
your partner in the car when you're like
[__] this is [__] 25,000 [__] and
then also you just like what should we
do I don't know I think word no let's
just go eat breakfast let's do Roland
should have done in in No Country For
Old now don't tell that rotten child we
made what were the final what were the
answer what you say 3K 3K $800
and5 they won and to get out of here on
this they
won
$8 what a joke any this is so funny yeah
so funny these dogs so glad we we took
the time to put it back together again I
love it we've got three big things
coming up in like three day in a
three-day span Daniel's taping on 11-11
us doing our show in New York identical
dads on 1112 at arsnova and stamp town
which is happening in La three different
cities 13th we love you guys and oh [__]
we got to get back to work peace see
you
[Music]
around